بعد اخر ايضا في هذه الحرب حيث الغت
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه قانونا ضمن
التغيير القضائي الذي اقترحه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو يقيد قدره
المحكمه على مراجعه قرارات الحكومه وعلق
وزير العدل الاسرائيلي بالقول ان قرار
المحكمه العليا ابطال قانون المعقوليه
الان مخالف لروح الوحده المطلوبه اثناء
الحرب اما وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اتمار بنفير فقال ان الغاء القانون
المتعلق بالحد من اشراف المحكمه على
الحكومه والوزراء خطير ويضر بالمجهود
الحربي وغرد زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
يائير لابيد قائلا انه يدعم بشكل كامل
قرار المحكمه العليا بشان الغاء قانون
المعقوليه واضاف لابيد انه اذا بدات
المحكمه خلافها مع المحكمه مجددا فهو فهي
لم تتعلم شيء شيئا من 87 يوما من الحرب
حسب
تعبيره معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره
احمد هزيم احمد ماذا عن التفاعلات حتى
الان عقب قرار المحكمه
العليا عبد القادر التفاعلات حتى اللحظه
كل من موقعه وكل من موقفه من هذا القانون
بس لكن اذا سمحت لي على عجاله تذكير بماذا
فعلت الهيئه العليا للمحكمه العليا في
اسرائيل وهي مكونه من جميع قطاط المحكمه
العليا وهم 15 قاضيا هم اسقطوا قانون
الغاء حجه المعقوليه اي ان اسرائيل قبل
هذا القانون اي قبل في السنوات الماضيه
كانت تدار عبر حجه المعقوليه وهي حق
للمحكمه العليا تقوم على اساسه بالغاء بعض
قوانين يصدرها الكنيست الاسرائيلي بحجه ان
هذا القانون غير معقول او غير مطابق لبعض
الحقوق الاساسيه نحن نعلم ان اسرائيل ليست
بها دستور فهذه المحكمه والقوانين
الاساسيه التي يصدرها الكنيست هما
الذان يؤطر للعلاقه بين الدوله والمواطن
من جهه وبين السلطات الثلاث من جهه اخرى
والمحكمه اليوم قامت بالغ باسقاط قانون
الغاء المعقوليه والذي كان يحد من هذا من
قدره المحكمه على الغاء قوانين وتشريعات
يسنها الكونجرس عفوا يشنها يسنها الكنيست
الاسرائيلي وهذا هو في صلب الخلاف السياسي
الذي كان قائما مطلع العام الحالي او مطلع
العام الماضي وحتى قبيل الحرب بين
الائتلاف بقياده بنيامين نتنياهو والذي
كان يسعى لما يقول بانها تعديلات قضائيه
وبين المعارضه التي ترى بان هذه التعديلات
من شانها ان تحد من الديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه وان تضع البلاد تحت سطوه
وسلطه اليمين المتطرف الان وبعد ان قامت
المحكمه اولا بالتصويت على على حقها في
الغاء قوانين اساسيه ب 12 قاضي مقابل 15
صوتت على اسقاط قانون الغاء الحجه حجه
المعقوليه بثمانيه مقابل سبعه اصوات ردود
الفعل كما سمعنا من بن كفير ووزير العدل
هم انتقدوا هذا القرار واعتبروه انه ضربا
للوحده الوطنيه بينما انصار المعارضه
الذين تظاهروا تباعا كل كل اسبوع حتى
بدايه الحرب ضدها قوانين ومشاريع التعديل
القضائي كما كان يسميها ائتلاف الائتلاف
الحاكم بقياده نتنياهو هم الان يتنفسون
السعداء لكن هذا كله من شانه ان يضرب اكثر
في الوحده او وحده الصف الاسرائيلي بعد
سلسله من التسريبات والخلافات السياسيه
على مدى الايام الماضيه بين جناح نتنياهو
وجناحي بن كفير وسموت من جهه والجناح
المعارض وحتى جناحي بيلي جانس وايزن كوت
من جهه اخرى على مواضيع عده تتعلق بالحرب
تتعلق باليوم التالي تتعلق بدخول الجيش
الى المرحله الثالثه اضف الى ذلك الان
الخلاف او ما يتوقع ان يكون خلافا حادا
بين هؤلاء الاطراف على مساله الغاء او
اسقاط قانون الغاء حجه المعقوليه وما قد
يسببه ربما من تاثير في مجلس الحرب وبيلي
جانس وايزن كوت هم من انصار الغاء او
اسقاط هذا القانون الذي يحد من المحكمه
العليا وسلطاتها وبن جفير وسموت هم من
انصاره وفي حال تم مهاجمه المحكمه العليا
او مهاجمه القضاه او او او او تمت خروج
مظاهرات في الشارع الاسرائيلي من قبل
اليمين المتطرف سيؤثر بلا شك على تماسك
مجلس الحرب وعلى قدره اسرائيل على اداره
المعركه هناك في قطاع غزه احمد هزم من تل
ابيب شكرا جزيلا لك